Here's my approach to the problem.
Here's our axes.
Here's my function, f(x).
Now, the problem is I'm given some value of y,
and I want to find the value of x that corresponds to that such that f(x) equals y.
The strategy we had before was to just start at the 0 point
and go out step-by-step-by-step, but that's going to be slow if there are lots of steps.
My approach is going to be--first I'm going to take one step forward,
and then if the value of f(x) is still below y, then I'm going to double how far out I go.
I'm going to keep on doubling how far out I go and checking--
1, 2, 4, 8, 16 units out--until I've got bounds.
Here I have this value that I doubled. F(x) was less than the desired y.
When I went all the way out to here, f(x was greater than the desired y.
I know that the right x has to be somewhere within this range.
That gives me the low and the high that I get by doubling.
Now I'm going to find the exact value or close to exact value within low and high by halfing.
First doubling, now halfing.
I look in here, say what's halfway between low and high. That's at this point.
F(x) there is still too high.
Now I know I must be somewhere in this half.
I go halfway there. That's still too high.
Now I know I must be in this half, and I keep on doing that process
until I zero in on the right value.
That's the strategy. Now let's see what the code looks like.
Here's my function "inverse."
I'm going to have my smallest delta--the smallest amount that I move out--be 1/1024.
That's going to get me to within three significant digits.
I'm going to build up this f inverse function.
I was given y = f(x).
I'm going to build up x = f_1(y).
I do that first by finding the low and high bounds--
it's got to be somewhere in there--and then doing a binary search
somewhere in between that low and high to find a value that's accurate to within delta.
Here's how I find the bounds.
I start off, and I just keep on doubling until I find a value that's high enough.
What I keep on doing is narrowing down the interval between low and high
until they come out to be the same--until the interval has disappeared.
If I'm too high, then I change the low. Otherwise, I change the high value.
That makes the interval smaller and smaller.
If I hit it exactly, I go ahead and return the x value.
If I haven't hit it exactly, then I know I'm somewhere in between the two,
and I just check out which one to do.
Now, I've defined some functions here to help me test what I've done.
I've defined the square and the 10^x functions.
Now I define those inverses.
The logarithm is just the inverse of the power of 10,
and sgrt is the inverse of square using the function I defined.
Can also do a cube root as the inverse of the cube function.
Then I'm defining some tests.
For these sets of numbers, I'm going to test these functions--sqrt, log10, and cuberoot,
and I'm going to test them against the correct mathematical functions as defined by Python.
These are the ones I've defined with inverse.
These are the ones Python defines, and here's my individual test.
Here's what I get when I run the tests.
For each of the numbers and for each of the functions here is the result I compute
with my inverse function.
Here is the actual results, and you can see the differences are all in the 0.001 or less.
That's true for small numbers, and it's true even as we go up to bigger numbers like 10^8.